[Musica]
bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo arrivati all'ultimo episodio
di paranoia in un altro il nostro vino
tanto mi mangi biscotti da 12 ore sono
qui ma vaffan
no sono svenuta la donna cammas kamura
ho letto malissimo scusa pista camorra o
di temi che il vicino e vicino sta
urlando da sopra il pozzo ha dato questa
orgasmo a stai bene mi senta camera si
ma tira una scala attira la couleur
bravo a quest'uomo è utile guardate la
dote la donna sembra che stai male
nostro caduto da un pezzo di 14 metri ma
sto bene ma devi andare all'ospedale si
guarda vorrei levarmi da questa casa
come se fosse l'ultima cosa che facciamo
quando rispondevi al campanello così
sono venuto dentro e si sentite gli ho
urlato in faccia perché è una persona
che non può venire in casa mia di nuovo
la free enzo ragazzi siamo nella free
hands on del mio uso fa mi ha inseguito
per tutta la casa fino a lì sotto
e non era soltanto mostro dei capelli
nell'acqua un fax e il piano che si
suonava da solo e delle strane voci non
ce la faccio sono spaventata sono sicuro
di esserlo thai a casa mia per stasera a
vedi che ci aveva il doppio fine davvero
vivo qui da cinque anni hanno mai
incontrato un mostro prima d'ora però
non chiatta questo posto finché non ti
addormenti rai che uomo però è che
l'uomo con due pali sarà il corso via
come se non ci fosse stato un domani
invece la sostanza è molto pulita molto
più di casa mia e tu sei un uomo pensate
che tragedie comunque miss takamura
posso chiederti qualcosa ma alquanto la
dai denti ti libera di essere a casa tua
qua dentro perfetto lega sono un po
tardi quindi dormi dove vuoi quando vuoi
e come vuoi io dormirò sul divano mista
camorra prendi il lettore e ora l'uomo
perché per una patata si fa questo ed
altro devo riposare o che lei riposa
susto lette siamo tranquilli cannabis ai
tornato cosa fa il sopra ali sta
dormendo profondamente questo è bello
vedi che un maniaco di merda lo sapevo e
che sembra andare male con la casa
quindi prenderà un eva ben riposati fa
quel che cazzo vuoi riposiamoci tutti
quanti insieme in passionata mente cosa
hai fatto a casa mia
buongiorno 4 siamo già al giorno 4 cos'è
cos'è sta roba
chi è che sei in cat cos'è sotto e
camera mia questa no questa questa è
casa mia non è un sogno questo cazzo
perché perché sono tornata non voglio
stare qui ancora per un solo secondo
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo già nel culo dove
la casa dice io come faccio uscire casa
devo andare a piedi sotto di uscire e xi
e xix porca la [ __ ] paga rileva beh
tra tutti i posti in cui potevi essere
dove cazzo sei apparso davanti no no sta
lontano da lontano e che posso passare
la mia vita scappato mongoloide io però
è non è che posso far a vita
lo dico chiaro e tondo dai che poi
fuggire fuggi fuggi toglie la tua da
mandare a chiusa la porta era chiusa
timori se la famiglia perché sto
giocando alle due e mezza di notte a
questa merda perché io santo visto che
arrivando in mano vi giuro
no no no no porca [ __ ] no e quello è
quello che per fare l'unico o qualcuno
mi butto nel pozzo
e questo per forza e poi questo è il
porto col culo che ciò il pozzo convinto
a vita ma la tensione ogni volta se mi
si punta ti giuro uno schiaffo qualcosa
tiro stava già state non ho fatto niente
io non è colpa mia ma sei seria chi
ascolta ma vero non poter ma non è stato
lui o questa chiave che ho trovato una
chiave a caso per ben tre ragazze chiavi
a casta di chiavi a cazzo è che lui
l'ultima volta e questa è perfetto
negarne un ave rimaneva perfetto di buio
è così pericoloso
non c'è una torcia da qualche parte non
lo so oggi a non rompere il cassettone
degli attrezzi ragazzo a flash al caffè
ci andiamo
meraviglia c'è un cane ha mai finto a
perfetto la pecora
c'è una scritta sul muro c'è scritto non
farsi cuocere la pasta difficile vedere
nell'oscurità però c'è scritto 24 36
perfetto è il codice del computer ho già
capito
l'unica cosa che mi manca col computer
dovrei aver finito non c'è più castrista
casa
che non ci sia un altro giovane libero e
tanto è che cazzo sto campanello se è
quello stronzo di prima lo prendo a
schiaffi in faccia giuro è veramente non
è possibile
eccolo lì non è successo niente presuma
perché mi hai portato qui mentre dormivo
calmati
io non ho idea di che cosa è lo sapevo
che non era stato lui cosa ti prendi
gioco di meno veramente siccome non lo
sai
calmati per favore non mi hai detto tu
stessa di voler tornare a casa l'altro
giorno è svegliato la scorsa notte mi ha
detto che sarebbe andato tutto ok quindi
alla fine sono stato io a tornare a casa
da solo paranormale stata la norma
l'activity non ho capito se è posseduta
sta ragazza non gliel'ha data neanche
stavolta piuttosto di non darla ragazzi
figli di legno che non può essere non
l'ho fatto io stavo dormendo la scorsa
notte noi invece sei stata posseduta da
un demone miss takamura devo devo
cavarmela da sola brava zia mista cavour
a buy affanculo non te la do the sun hui
li monsters and just nip è solo
un'illusione o è veramente un mostro è
veramente un mostro non sono pazzo non
dire questo se tu non hai visto niente è
stato veramente un mostro non voglio
vederti più va via e va bene ragazzi
l'abbiamo l'abbiamo cacciato ma se
niente fosse se succede ancora correrò
per lei ma [ __ ] non te la do
pomigliano lurido non sono allucinazioni
lui esiste davvero scarsi di telefono
una donna sentite sarà mia madre che mi
chi sei tu e mia madre mamma aiutami per
favore c'è un mostro nella casa sto
provando uccidermi se l'unica la quale
posso chiedere aiutami ti prego vieni
qui da iride che cazzo ri di madonna che
deve ammazzato la leggendo le
barzellette di geronimo stilton sapevo
che eri pazza non chiamarmi più non
voglio sentir ma veramente messo a madre
sei una [ __ ] potessero sbatte in
autostrada non sono pazza non sono pazza
in e tua madre ma non è tua madre una
[ __ ] qualunque tranquillo giorno 5
hai pure dormito in casa ma com è ormai
sono un incontro alla morte certa
ho sentito qualcosa e sarà il mostro da
dove arriva
vabè modo 18 tanto ormai fa o che cazzo
a bella del sì che sa infatti no non la
semplice nella serie dove si cos'è
questo se io io non ci posso più ci
posso credere
e lui indicato è caduto e via devo
correre
devo nascondermi tanto per cambiare e mi
ha preso porca ladra a scott amico mio
cantiamo la canzoncina insieme che sono
tutti contenti di birdlife è il rocker
non so a the damned sono morto the snow
white
ai ragazzi è stato bello ascolta zio
giochiamo a carte
se vuoi che c'è una partita si perde
saviano al culo che i say that can stay
away e cos'è ha preso un pupazzo un
orsacchiotto parcheggio ricerca c'è
scritto mickey tratto fatto con paint
meraviglio a questo pupazzo l'hai fatto
prevedi che mia zia ma sono convinto che
sia mia zia cioè ormai sosta cosa in
testa ma vero a mio dire questa mia zia
e solo che volevo dirlo a qualcuno
perché non vorrei dirtelo ma tua sorella
è una [ __ ] di quelle [ __ ] che non
per il non rompermi i [ __ ] contorno
si vabbé ma sei francia come la vita
adesso la adesso dovrei andare a dirgli
che sono contento che abbia avuto il
bambino a paroli sto preparando gli
associati perfetta che farò anche un
animaletto per temi chi sa magari quando
andrea liceo sarà in un pochettino
troppo grande e prove se ne fermava io
dormo ancora quei pupazzi e al prefetto
quindi io adesso li ho fatti
congratulazioni quindi quella e mia zia
che non si trucca da tre anni ma perché
prima mi ha ucciso allora che cazzola
stavo cercando ma a è per questo che è
venuta qui per cercare lo sa chiotto io
per tesi a fare qualsiasi cosa
col ma come cazzo ti voglio bene sia zia
batti cinque zia brava così mi ha
stuprato mura vista kamura a e lo
stronzo di miura sei tu se sono vivo
come
era così preoccupato che non rispondevi
è ma perché tu sono il mio campanello
dieci volte al giorno brutto so io non
ho potuto aiutarla ma comunque l'ho
amata fino all'ultimo quando sono state
esaminate all'ospedale hanno trovato dei
segni di schizofrenia
vabbè mica dopo che mai ricco sono
zombie per cinque notti grazie ai cazzi
non ho ancora capito se la vera
un'allucinazione ah sei tornata pure ok
non penso di dimenticare nulla e valuta
credo demadonna le madonne e quello
stronzo giuro ma basta
vai a casa tua sapevo che te ne stavi
andando quindi sono venuto a salutarti
puoi stare meglio con mia mamma ma non
devi stare meglio con tua madre di
ammazzarla di botte tua ma devi
ammazzare di schiaffi in faccia finché
non muore e la casa che mia zia ha
lasciato a me quindi mi piacerebbe
vivere qui se potessi ti accompagna la
stazione non ci sono molti taxi che
girano con fuori grazie mille sarebbe
fantastico sarò di ritorno molto presto
zia ma stai parlando allo zombie che
gira ancora per casa ma [ __ ] ma
non tornerò mai più in vita mia zia zio
parenti ma date morire tutti ragazzi è
finito paranoia che stato fantastico a
parte il fatto che io non ho mai avuto
una zia così brutta i talenti e di
truccarsi li prego sono appagato addosso
per tutta la durata di sta roba perché
ho iniziato a mezzanotte ho finito alle
io non so come dormirò stasera lega non
lo so good and hutch anche labed ending
come ce l'ha ben ending come fai a
essere ben n
voglio sapere vabbè così va bè ragazzi
con crollo qui l'episodio è stato
fantastico come gameplay rpg era nome
pezzo non giocavo 1 comunque spero che
vi sia piaciuto è una serie è stata una
storia un po diversa dal solito ma ho
voluto fanno lo stesso e niente ragazzi
se mi è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
a quanto vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e con i video trovate la
descrizione so se questi scontri cv da
un passo vinto le ragazze